that the only force in our society
that's strong enough to in any sense
compete with the mass of electronic
media is the educational system and I
see the American educational system in
really rather dire straits and I'll
simply talk about the arts the arts have
been systematically removed from most of
our schools and so unless you grow up in
an affluent community you're not likely
to have the arts in your education which
means not only are we not developing an
audience for the arts and that's one
thing but more important the new
generation of Americans are not but
receiving those Spurs to personal growth
that the arts create the purpose of arts
education is not to create more artists
it's not to create more audiences the
purpose of arts education is to create a
complete human being who can lead a
productive life in a free society you
can't do that just through academics and
athletics there are certain things that
you can only learn in stories in songs
you can only see in images when you take
this out of a kid's education you
impoverish their possibilities both
individually and socially it's as as
important to educate a child or an
adolescence emotions as it is their mind
and when you take this out of the
education of sixty million American kids
and you focus on developing low-level
work skills I think you have in the
offing a cultural educational economic
and political disaster
you